what up pip nation welcome back to
another episode of the h3 podcast live
here with my beautiful wonderful co-host
ela Cline you look my life ela cloners I
should I say Gila cloners how are you
doing on this Friday very good thank God
it's Friday looking for this Saturday
good job everybody for getting through
to Friday you know I got to say before I
think for the longest time the weekend
didn't mean anything to us that's true
and just recently last week was our
first time doing this what we're like
you know what we're gonna work super
hard during the week day and fry it and
Saturday Sunday I'm not even gonna open
my email yeah
no work I'm not even good I'm not gonna
think about it I'm not gonna oh and it's
actually been I mean so far we've only
done it one time but it's it it was good
it's really good and you forget how much
you need it like psychologically right
because the whole thing for that one
year was like you're working every day
and you never have anything to look
forward to there's no like separation in
your time and it was kind of driving me
crazy yeah so anyway happy Friday
everybody
god bless the weekend am i right TGI
Fridays this episode is brought to you
by quit the bull ass toothbrush that'll
clean your mouth
quicker than a than a toothpick
toothpick Dollar Shave Club god bless
him neck beard challenge told more about
that later and of course my new favorite
game on the block Elder Scroll Legends
more about those guys later today we
have a special special guest my friends
you may know him from our second channel
Ethan Angela we did a whole series about
this guy and one of my biggest regrets
was not making a video about him on the
main channel he's such a prolific legend
Jimmy Lee the jersey outlaw
now he's here in the studio with us
we're gonna bring him in soon but I want
to bring everybody up to speed so you
know what we're dealing with here so
first of all let me tell you the story
about how we found out about Jimmy so on
the subreddit there was this post didn't
get too much attention but was
fascinating fascinating then you're
snoozing it doesn't really work gonna
have to beg you to do it everybody's
been making fun of me because I know
they say h3 podcasts in a nutshell
fascinating the soundboard and you know
what's you know what I mean and then
like I was looking through our last
episode and I just clicked in one random
spot out of three hours and it's me
going that's fascinating I guess maybe I
do something let's put on the soundboard
tried to do like I like it if [ __ ]
somebody will get on their [ __ ] fast me
maths fascinating fascinating it's good
fascinating man Frank anyway so got it
III said it and I wasn't even I do say
that too much all right now it's meme
there was a post on our subreddit it was
like boogie says I was or sub whatever
somebody says I was molested as a kid
and Ethan fascinating whatever [ __ ] you
guys me minami where was a story about
Jimmy Layton so we found out about Jimmy
Lee on our subreddit there was a post
and he's like I have this dentist in New
Jersey or Philadelphia and one of the
two and he my dentist gave me a mixtape
while he was working on my teeth of his
band called Jimmy the jersey outlaw and
he was like so weirded out by it that he
never came back to that dentist but what
he did is googled his name cuz he was
fascinated fascinated by the guy and
what he found was was incredible right
so what he found was that he was also
making comedy sketches in his dentist
practice beyond passing out his mixtape
so
here's that video this is how we found
Jimmy just to give you an idea it's
called one [ __ ] up Dennis aka one
[ __ ] up Dennis the non cheeky version
this credit goes wait so so he's yeah
and then they're like just I mean you
know it's give you an idea of what we're
dealing with here and then here's a
timestamp below one specific moment that
caught my to YouTube Dublin it's always
YouTube there they're the source of all
problems in my life ela so just for the
record this is his real assistant that
he put into this sketch you know and
he's married he has kids
he's probably a great family man for all
I know I don't know but yeah you pick a
number between 68 and 70 I did a girl so
good last night Natalie that the police
came three times I'm gonna school yeah
yeah graduate with me you graduate magna
[ __ ] laude so anyway so but this is a
whole like total romp right this this
sketch was something that I'd never seen
before
and so we made a video about it on our
second channel they they you know got
his attention and we ended up meeting up
with the guy but I would say even before
I get to that what he's most famous for
is his street comedy mmm-hmm let me give
you a taste of this
[Music]
so his comedy style is essentially
roasting people he's never met before
it's it's incredible what he gets away
with yeah hey how you doing yeah big fan
how long you been black it's really
great to watch I mean it's really
something fascinating I'm so aware of
myself saying it no fascinating that
took way today we gotta work on that
dude we gotta be you gotta be you gotta
be Doc Holliday on that fascinating
button all right what else we got like
he's like a drive-by insult artist like
when people go on the show like the
roasts right and they know what they're
getting into and they're volunteering
them right right right
but it's just walking on this street and
just insulting people like brutally well
ela don't you know when you walk on the
street you consent to be roasted by
Jimmy Lee let me see what else forget he
brought cameramen with him I wonder if
they know what they're getting
themselves into I don't think they've
ever worked together before I was gonna
be interesting to see the UH see how
that works out this is one of my
favorites here he's talking these old
ladies
what did he say that you guys are
Cougars you know Freddy food cook you
guys are Cougars Freddy Krueger's
anything to make it your 10 - 5 X - 10
yeah and PS plastic surgery it's all
rough telling a girl to get plastic
surgery to be honest but that's just
that's the art that's the harder you do
here you're a stripper well she went and
got a boob job two weeks you because
it's all she could fight for I mean he
paid this girl to come with their anyway
you guys get the idea if you're not
familiar we've got some more clips plan
let's sit here what else we got sports
yes what oh this one wait this is the
one okay I want to watch this one later
um hold on one sec wait where is this
yeah alright so that's pretty much Jimmy
in a nutshell
here's a good one
we're here at Comic Con in Philly I
don't want to tell you hey guys today I
discovered black and white television
let's hear it right now
black and white TV back from the 60s but
it's back your name she's so scared of
it and your name Jordan we're Jordan in
annum their date they have a lot of fun
they mix it up a little bit tonight
she's gonna be black he's gonna be white
they do whatever now they gotta do a
little detention so anyway oooh to get a
little attention ish he's an old school
guy and then so anyway this is his
comedy and then after all that we made a
cup several videos about it we went out
and we met the guy
all right but tonight I wanted to go to
bar okay this court doesn't work it
shows up on this yeah
all right the discord doesn't work guys
so we went out to lunch and he started
like kind of like [ __ ] I couldn't tell
if he was actually trying to [ __ ] this
girl so anyway just I'm trying to give
you as much full context as I can
because I think a lot of people this was
a long time ago and since then since we
made these videos together we've kept in
touch we've cut in touch big time I
explained we I mean Jamie emails me very
frequently he pretty much emails me like
five times a day we're best friends
he knows ela - my inbox clean yeah it
wasn't personal but I I endured it
because I'm like Jimmy's a legend I mean
the guy's the guy's a legend so look
that's kind of brutal but it's just like
we're just truck worth trying to be
forthright trying to be frank here and
Jimmy he's a legend I'm ready to bring
him in here we go we got so Jimmy Jimmy
Lee welcomed the legend you just did a
full intro on your welcome board
appreciate Jimmy also brought his
cameraman with them you want to check
this what a check audio make sure now
what's the cameraman for well the
cameraman is just to make me feel good
because when you get older and nobody
cares about you and pays attention you
have to pay people to hang out with you
that's kind of what's happening that was
like wow yeah yeah things are things are
tough for me now oh my god I'm having a
rough time
I'm setting you up yeah what's the setup
I got a new girlfriend though you know
about her
no oh she's a blow-up doll mm-hmm she
takes my breath away
nice mm-hmm so what is your name
Sarkis Sarkis yeah Sarkis and I met at
Folsom County Prison many years ago it
was actually an inmate mm-hmm are you
familiar with oh my god
all right audio good young Fouquet
enough no more movement yeah do you know
what you're getting yourself into
well we share a reaction yeah funny guy
he's one funny guy so how are you dude
how you been um I'm having some some
problems Ethan wait wait things are fine
how are you in life tell me like things
are good in life things are good I don't
have any complaints well I'd I have a
couple complaints I had a dog I told you
about the dog we got rid of you know
about him the kid was in the hallway
with his leg up in the air how to get
rid of the dog was awkward my son I
would walk in the hall we had his leg up
in the air so the dog and then the dog
kept teaching a wife on a roll over and
play dead
I had to get rid of the dog yeah we
called the dog Egypt in every room he
left the pyramid right a dog's gone okay
good yeah good but is it a possibility
to ask you how are you doing like not as
it hard yeah like how are you though I'm
doing fine I'm a former overall how have
you been since the last we saw each
other cuz it was a pretty intense moment
for me like it's it's no secret like
between us that it's it can be awkward
for people to be around you right like
you know that you elicits that response
why why do people think that when I'm
just a funny guy trying to have fun why
it is that perception happen
you don't know no or I hear die jokes or
cringe and I'm just trying to be funny
and cute people take the whole thing the
wrong way okay oh no okay that don't do
that well this is great
okay so here okay well I actually have a
clip one in particular and I'll just
show it now because I think this is a
great place to jump it well if I had to
tell you
I think it's because you tend to be look
way too offensive right but instead of
well you just met right but people don't
get that it's cute they get oh we get
the wrong way if they don't know me
right right but none of them know you
that's that's the problem so we have to
get famous so everybody knows me and
then when I do my stick I'll be okay
yeah you guys so that's the key you've
got like a catch-22 where you're like my
my bits are just mean unless I'm famous
and then there's a no no cuz they'll
know my caveat it's kind of getting in
the way of you getting there
maybe or not hmm well let me let me
watch this particular clip because this
one struck me as as being particularly
brutal two weeks ago so like you just
you're basically just like I'm making
like brutal fat jokes actually these
girls and the thing is like they don't
you know they don't expect it you're
like hey do you want like how do you
introduce them how do you get them to
come in the video well a lot of times
they see the cameras and the models and
the photographers they know something's
happening right that's a little
preemptive bring them in but they don't
know what's gonna happen so you get that
they be candid response because if you
kind of tell them ahead of time hey
we're gonna do insult jokes you want to
do it it takes away from the the
candidates response and then it's not as
funny and then there's sometimes we'll
do Clips and the other people don't
react and then it's not funny because
both people have to react to make it
funny so you'll do some clubs people get
upset or they they are not interested
well do you ever feel like maybe I took
this too far yeah but I never had any
filters you know that's that's a good
thing in a bad I think now when I'm
doing my business and running a company
you know if you saw me doing that you
wouldn't even know it's me because I
have write multiple locations 50
employees I own my own denture lab I got
10 Doc's at work for me and I got a big
outfit and we're you're successful
dentist what is your passion is a comedy
or dentistry well I have one dream left
you know I've
made enough money I have a big company I
have a wonderful family at them in my 30
years two kids my late my last drive
traveled all over my last thing Ethan I
want to do is just get famous and known
that's the only thing yeah that's the
only voice my life what is that about
for you I had a void since I was a kid I
always wanted to be a celebrity in a
store you know what's wrong what about
it I never I never got past it
what why um there really it's a good
question I don't know what I think my
grandfather when I was real young took
me to the 500 club and I saw the
celebrities and I got that buzz and then
in college the casinos came to Laennec
City I used to go see all the shows and
I just got a high from entertainment I
wasn't doing this for money I'm not
making money doing it there's a passion
from here so what does your wife think
about that she thinks I'm nuts and I got
my oldest son that thinks I'm nuts and
my young one thinks I'm hysterical what
does she think about all the female
attention you get because I see in your
videos you're often escorted by
beautiful young women who they're
showpieces and sizzle pieces and I do
security guards now - based on the
comic-con I did them it's basically just
an adjunct or a showpiece or like if you
go to your the steak place there's the
sizzle and then there's the substance
the substance that the steaks good -
sizzles how the restaurant looks and if
there's pretty waiter girl sizzle for it
it's a sizzle effect what do you like
these girls modeling agencies okay
that's that's basically all they are in
the security guards a security guard
agency it's just a business transaction
I pay the girls for the day or the
security girls revenge but they do they
create an effect God and an illusion is
really what it is right so it's a
marketing tool is it possible are you
are you gonna be there the whole time
it's a little hard for me to focus on
are you filming are you filming
we have three cameras in here Jimmy I
mean I don't but it's hard for me to
focus on you when you when get out dude
oh can you stay and do stills or now not
really no this will do - still all right
okay no it's pretty yeah here's really
pretty intimate for us like we just have
any comas
okay so tell me about tell me about the
year.i we first learned about you when
one of your clients from your dentist
practice was like this dudes hanging out
mixtapes right is that something you're
still doing now I stopped music and
tried this how come you I don't know why
was there a moment when you realize
that's off the 1f Dennis was there a
moment when you like when did you why
did you stop handing out your mixtapes
because clearly that worked I mean that
got you high grade art I did music and
um I got some songs on radio open for
some big acts and then I kind of
realized that it flatlined and I'll tell
you what made that happen
um I wrote a song Spanish girl in 2011
and it was a ballad which I normally
don't write and it was a beautiful song
it was probably one of my best songs I
didn't got some radio play and it didn't
go anywhere and I said that's it with
music I I put in I put out something it
was like a Mona Lisa
was it Annabelle this girl on listen to
it in Spanish girl no Jimmy Lee listen
to a piece of it I mean that's what made
me stop on that this song did you go big
listen to just you realize when this
song didn't go where you wanted it that
alright let's watch this video
yeah who's the girl another model she's
a model Jen artis
that's you singing that's me singing I'm
really talented with music that's it by
a producer so it's a new write it I
wrote every song is are you every song
I've done is written by me there's no
cover sign do you get a lot of female
attention when you're doing singing and
song writing yeah you get you get
attention when you do entertainment I
get more female attention with music and
more middle-aged guys with comedy but
you get attention no matter what it is
like do you ever does it or do you ever
feel tempted because I know you're
married man I don't need to do that
I'm the ham I like just to be the
spotlight that's my buzz not not running
with chicks and that I just like to be
we were joggers last night I had
wolfgang puck over at the table taking I
need to be in the center of the line way
that's me that's my buzz got it so you
asked me earlier why about entertainment
that that's it they have a lot of
insecurities
this is really something
[Music]
it doesn't sound like it's it's mixed
[Music]
it sounds good listen that's rock and
roll baby
yeah listen to the course a tiny bit
more just where you were at that's the
bridge
where are you right now Philadelphia
2012 so um that what happened with
comedy was it was a fluke that I got
into comedy I was doing a music show one
night and the lady introduced me to a
comedy Booker and I said you know my
wife always tells me to do comedy and he
goes well we have an open mic come down
in a week so I got some jokes and I went
down and I did like five minutes and
people left I said alright I'll try this
that's exactly what happened it was
actually Ethan a fluke so would you want
to roast one of us
you're like a roast comedian right yeah
all of a sudden all of a sudden were
having this is serious thing and now I
got to go into Jimmy Lee mode let's tell
all right so you who my roasting a my
roasting could start with me you want me
to say kitty long for you yeah I could
take it well
you know we all know can i Ethan first
of all while the viewers are listening
can I can I confess something that a lot
of people don't know and I think HeLa
doesn't know may I do this on the air
yeah okay I don't know what it is
okay well Ethan I'm here to tell you and
he'll I'm here to tell you that I am
Ethan's real father and I just wanted to
tell you on the air live I didn't want
to I didn't want to do this you know I
want this is and and I I have photos
home and everything you did I know you
think about mom and dad anything the
other thing is your mom and I know you
don't believe this is it Kitana
what is that what if she is
afro-american wait what is good is
racist
no no oh
so yeah I'm your real dad mom what the
[ __ ] your mom is yes and I know you
don't know this right but you need to
know this and I have photos and I can
bring them in later and [ __ ] my mom is
probably texting now your mom is Akutan
and I am your real daddy's and so son
so I'm half-black so yes you just don't
know that my mom's black well with that
would be a surprise it is true because
we had a lot of treatments skin
treatments done with you when you were
young we didn't mean beliefs we bleach
you a lot yes yes all right so that is a
confession in heal I wanted you to be
here
I like that I like that I asked you to
roast me and then you're my dad is the
hardest road yeah let's hear some
material let's hear some of that fresh
well I have some new material which is
like this is an Armani my shirt
yes Salvation Armani and I was telling a
thin the difference between the Jew and
a kanuni said what is the difference
between the Jew and a Cano I said it
Knut tips and I can keep that joke to
myself he'll if you don't get and I
remember I remember the canoes tip
unlike Jews shoes don't tip tip like
money because Jew
tip like money so Ethan oh you know
although good canoes aren't supposed to
tip right so so Ethan when he was a
little boy we took him to the zoo when
he was five when we left them there and
this is what what happened this was the
the result and we had him work in a pet
store when he was 11 and people used to
come and ask oh how big he get so he
quit that job when he was a teenager he
was a lifeguard in a car wash one summer
it got wet so he quit doing that and he
went to high school he graduated ninth
in his class actually out of 10 and he
was hila honor student in high school
yes your honor no your honor thank you
your honor
and you want any more he did go to
college two years heel and he quit and I
said Ethan were you a dropout how do you
know so much about me I'm your father
okay it all makes sense yes mm-hmm yes
hey Jimmy do me a favor take off those
glasses you're making aspect oh oh I
never heard that joke before hey Jimmy
how long have you been white I'll be
black with you in a minute
now one of my new one of my jokes is
when I do the blacks I have my whole
setup but when I'm done I go I'll be
black with you in a minute I added that
one in that's powerful you seem to be
very focused on race like when you do
your bits well I was a marathon runner
and that's part of that reason yeah wise
you said I was focused on race and it's
cuz I was a marathon runner right when I
was younger right how'd she get that
beam you didn't race well I don't know
wife just it was bad no
it was good I just kept hearing you say
blacks in my mind yeah and I was like
dude is it racist to refer to black
people as blacks um HeLa I'll defer to
you one head from Israel but you say
that right you say you say the blacks
yes yeah I say yeah okay you know
chocolate mocha you know call it cream
yeah they're all different flavors
whatever you want to you know let's
watch some of your videos let me see cuz
I like you said I find it interesting
that you're surprised that people are
offended by your jokes you know what
bothers me is that people don't get me
and I'll tell you something interesting
Don Rickles who's my favorite comic he
said when he started out nobody got him
but when he hit everybody loved them and
that's why I say them early in a podcast
if I hit and get famous people will
expect to see what they see from me and
know I'll be accepted but when I'm an
unknown I'm an idiot I'm offensive I'm
crazy you're just thinking it's a matter
of time before people get the Jimmy Lee
phenomenon yes and then yes dad I'm
convinced they will I'm convinced they
well and maybe that's maybe that's me
thinking that something's gonna happen
that I want that won't but but that's
exactly what you just say you got to
keep dreaming here watch this clip yes
sir do people ever get upset sometimes
do have you ever got tried to be as
anyone try to fight you know never now
you know most people know because you
have an entourage your kid and sometimes
when they give up - Roger disarms people
yes but and when they get a little bit
offended we'll walk away like we were we
were at comic-con and there were a
couple instances and and my mic team
says let's just go keep walking not
really what happened well they think
there was your look or not they're not
interested or they get upset seems like
dangerous because some of this stuff I
feel like if you said this to the wrong
person you could be in danger well you
know what I did Dom did you watch that
hey you want some change I went into
canned and I did something stupid I
could have got killed I want to watch
that oh my god
thanks Bert hurdle hey you want some
change change Jimmy yeah you you want to
heal you'll die when you see this sounds
good okay okay so set this video up I go
to cam them with a bunch of quick Camden
it's the worst area of South Jersey it's
all okay
you know Medicaid people poor people and
I go to the bus station and watch its
historical it easily then you ask these
poor people if they want change well
watch what I do to do it it's it's kind
of it's it's it's state you talking
about danger this was stupid of me to do
now that I look back I would never do
this again because I could have really
got killed did you feel the in danger
while you were doing we left after about
a half hour because some people stored
it up and that was only with one guy you
didn't have the whole girls you know
yeah it was me and one guy on my phone
filming all right oh he's on your film
on my phone you're feeling oh wow this
is great let's have a look hey you want
some change poor people that's funny
because they're poor they probably do
want change well that's what makes it
cute watch what's cute
watch watch I became very popular
that's kind of a personal question right
it's funny cuz who would do this that's
why I don't get that's why you're
healing we have to get famous to people
well you know to see it that's like you
know that's almost like murdering your
whole family and then being like who
would do this much okay it's fun it's
cute it's funny who would do this I'm
not crazy over too long you're not that
crazy no I would never hurt a person I
just want to be noticed and have fun
that's really all it is so I guess
you're successful if that is your goal
let's keep watching
by the way how much money were you
giving this guy I had a bunch of
quarters at my core couple of fifty
bucks of quarters we had fun we had a
good time we had fun we had a lot where
most got killed Ali yeah a good time but
there's there's more good season let's
yeah one watch this lists let's find out
how big this guy's dick is pushing it
those on the phone so why so why do you
keep pushing the it's your big like are
you genuine you just like the
awkwardness you like to push that back a
bit AB it's good when the person reacts
and you have to be an 8 when you do
entertainment a an 8 you have to kind of
know without thinking about it whether
to push whether to go away like if
someone's really getting mad you
apologize you stop and you know you
don't put that clip in worse and when
somebody's going with you and they're
energetic and he's manic he like me you
push it so you know he was welcoming you
yeah he the energy was come here let's
keep the quarters rolling yeah right oh
there's more funny bits in this
watch what I make this guy doesn't seem
down with your [ __ ]
no but watch what I make him do Ethan
its historical watch a little more this
this big black eye bunnies he wants a
picture he wants a picture oh yeah watch
what this white dude does watch way he
knows you know he thinks I'm famous he
wants a picture watch him the black dude
on the right watch the white guy on the
Left what he does watch
it's st. Patrick's Day we did so you see
it's just being crazy and what I did was
I didn't think before I good this rule
and I watched it Ethan and I could have
actually got killed I would never go
into the danger zone like this this is
kind of being manically not thinking
before you do something that's probably
the most risque real real i did and that
was in a really bad areas daytime yeah
it was daytime it's like pranks in the
hood yeah it's kind of pricks in the
hood franksen hood it's a whole genre on
YouTube is it really your kind of yeah
you're tapping into the existing genre
honey drink so good it's when prankster
is going to like a black neighborhood
the hood and they'll do something like
what's a good one
pretend to other gas yeah pretend we're
siphoning gas out yeah those people in
the hood man it's our favorite kind of
video oh you like that so should we go
into downtown LA two more yeah let's uh
I'll find you I'll buy you the quarters
no I got it I gotta tell you guys that
that was a little scary
he decided when I left I said I wouldn't
do it again policy yeah yeah yeah
hopefully no one goes after y'all that
cameras looking nice yeah it's worse
than more than a couple quarters it's
yeah so that was we were talking about
danger video that's a danger video that
one so did you ever feel I mean you felt
threatened during this like what
happened what were they doing well at
the end some guy was like you know this
white guy is making a fool you and he
was getting real real loud and I thought
everybody's gonna band together and I
said Joe
if this is our exit point how much video
no not he goes I got about 15
eighteen minutes I said come on we'll
give it to Brian Oh edited into
five-minute video and we left so you
kind of knew when to go whoo let's keep
watching man this videos of is
spectacular okay your cameraman must be
insane to accompany on this like who's
Billy he's my photographer and best
friend and he was with me at lunch and
we ran over as a as a this was impromptu
we didn't play in this you're just like
hey there's a bunch of poor people here
let's run over if their lunch hour we
ran over for 20 minutes and did it we
didn't play in this it's on my phone
see some of them are cool I said you get
fan mail from you you got I feel you
have to acknowledge that watching this
is brutal
I love this [ __ ] you know why I grew up
on Don Rickles and people when I was
real young he'll it didn't get him yeah
but no of course and then I would be
dying and people are like but doc
doesn't go on the street and call it
like he's got a little more tact right
les yeah well he's more old-school poor
I there's I have no filter right that's
but it's the same style right yeah it's
your uncontrollable meme with full with
lots of energy that that's a good way to
describe me yeah I tried taking Viagra I
just got two inches taller it didn't
help I ended up with a stiff throat
right life like do you do you do this
jokes with your clients yeah to a point
with certain ones but you inside way
over the top no no no no insults enter
thank you online pungent jokes
what would you how far would you insult
someone in your dentist's chair I I
don't I don't you said like oh just
little one-liner punch it's like what's
one you would tell your patient well
I'll do I'll do you know I'll say you
know I got Madiga ROG that's why coming
back out I don't know how your marriage
is mine's not going to good you know I
said I'm married but my wife self I said
is your wife busy tonight
like I'm not installing them right you
know those people come back they come
back I have a lot of older people that
have been coming to me years and they
love me and they get me cuz they're 50
to 60 and it's the old-school jokes and
I know who not to do it with and you got
to remember I got five offices I own and
I work only out of one seeing patients
so I've had these patients for 17 years
they know me okay Audubon location and
the other locations I'm only in admit
traitor with staff and when I'm working
and running a business I'm looking at
metrics and numbers and measurements and
schedules and insurance aging reports
I'm not acting like an idiot
Jimmy Lee guy went in did run my
business I'm dr. James Weiner the
business administrator what you two
wouldn't even recognize or probably like
because of course I'm kind of I'm kind
of like that Superman and Clark Kent
it's two different you're married
differently well I dressed up when I'm
doing dead wearing that you were here is
the Dennis code problem yeah yeah and
when I'm doing administrative it's it's
nice jeans and a Robert Graham shirt
like that shirt Jimmy Lee meets Ethan
and Helena like you sure like that but
when I'm running my dental business I'm
a business guy and administrator and a
dentist and when I'm doing entertainment
I'm the high-energy crazy guy it's two
different person right let's take a
quick break
sure you want to run to the bathroom get
a drink or something we would like to
you know hangs out the men's room Ethan
may I may I
you may all the dance all right waise
say that chokes out the men's room yeah
may I yeah all the dicks I don't get the
main part like may I give you the answer
yeah yeah you don't have to fans now you
I'm doing well let's take a quick break
no I got two fans are up in the attic
I'll talk to you later okay yeah okay
yes call the dicks no just says okay you
may all right so well we're gonna you
know thank our sponsors right right yeah
it's powerful stuff well you are perfect
straight men because I was very friends
with Steve right who died Steve was a
straight guy de Morny
and we hung out for about 15-20 years
and I learned a lot from him he was a
singer and then he moved into the
straight row and marty was to comment
back when we were really young is when
there were two comedians PC in the 70s
80 was one but when that window TV we're
gonna take a quick quick break all right
I'm running the bathroom will be ready
in like three minutes no I just got it I
got
we're on a schedule it's from the
producer he's screaming at me it's not
me how you doing that's fine yeah it's
fine no problem how are you good good
how you guys we're still alive by the
way Oh oh my goodness mm-hmm all right
this is this is rougher this is rough
[Laughter]
yeah thank you I'm not gonna lie I'm
[ __ ] in I'm in over my head is this
energy I feel like I have no control
over this way that I blasted through all
my questions like five minutes and all
that was left was how many dicks are in
the bathroom
oh all right let me think the sponsors
all right wait I was just gonna say we
could bring then with the news after the
break if you need then maybe we should
take some questions you know be funny is
right okay
guys I'm sorry all right
here we go let me let me thank the
[ __ ] no no profanity please when we do
sponsor like a late night show all right
thank you to our wonderful sponsors let
me tell you was who's up this week quit
I got a bird not related to them start
over it's not related it's a bodily
function but the good thing is that quit
makes incredible the best toothbrush
I've ever used Anna burp like that it'll
get brushed out in moments here's the
thing about clip they've got this
incredible electric toothbrush that
basically times it out when you're
brushing at times it for three minutes
so you know you're getting a great brush
and the
I'm a guy that's obsessed with soft
bristles hey my bristles if they ain't
soft
they ain't brushing and this is softly
so it like times it out I think that
just pops on yeah that's just for the
refill you hear that that's vibrating
magic there's more than one use for this
toothbrush do you know what I'm saying
Gila anyway it times out your brush it
gives you the breast brush possible and
here's what these cool guys did go to go
to get quit get quit dot-com slash h3
look at this landing page they made this
is adorbs
hi ela Kleiner's here's what these guys
are doing for us right now
just for everybody watching this stream
a special everybody who's watching right
now if you go to the link get quick calm
slash h3 you get 50% off straight-up 50%
off that's it give it a shot because at
that price it's gonna be frickin
affordable and I guarantee this
toothbrush will change your life your
breath stinks change it with wit this
was voted like invention of the Year by
some people with clop we actually use
this I use it a home on is all I use so
anyway I'm a big fan of this product so
head on over if you're in the market for
a toothbrush that all shake your life
and you want 50% off go to get equipped
comm /hz if you're watching on youtube
that offer will expire but you'll still
get a free refill so thank you to get
quit appreciate you next up we have
Dollar Shave Club I mean come on I love
these guys welcome to the neckbeard
starter kit I don't if you guys saw our
last video on h3 about the 34 year old
virgin but we did the neck beard and his
honor I wanted to keep the neck beard
for this episode because I genuinely
loved it ela made me shave it off out of
shame yeah I was like hey we had some
meetings on that yesterday right and we
almost left
like that with the neckbeard and I was
like oh my god maybe you should shave it
well it's messed up because you're the
one after we shot that videos like I'm
gonna go shave off my neck beard and he
was like no you have to keep it did you
just told everyone else to do a neck
beard for the Fupa trooper nation and I
was like wow you're right what is the
lesson don't listen to me that's not the
lesson because the lesson has always
been listen to a lie and now I'm just
fully conflicted I wish I had the neck
beard because it's so good guys if you
go to you guys know what's up with
Dollar Shave Club they're one of our
great old faithful sponsors okay it's a
no-brainer
you get this great where is it no
brainer guys you want thickness you want
heaviness and a holder get real this is
the thickness by eat I'm telling you
could have a really good time with both
of these products
I'm telling you could have a really good
time with both these products it's thick
anyway you get four cartridges you get
shaved butter that's a $15 value if you
go to dollarshaveclub.com slash h3 you
get it for $5 $5 neck beard starter kit
it doesn't get better than that I swear
to you now this is the only razor that
doesn't give me razor burn and that's
not a burn that's a what outer pimps I
do really love this product so I
recommend it big time if you're in the
market for a razor you want to support
the show head on over to
dollarshaveclub.com and get that whole
package for only $5 cool thank you to
them and finally finally bethesda
favorite company make the best games on
this god-given earth they came out with
a new card game I spoke about it a
couple episodes ago called called Elder
Scroll Legends and it's a card game
online you can play it on your phone
your tablet your computer on all
platforms you can log out on your phone
log in where you left off on your
computer I've been playing this game a
lot I'm in pretty deep on the ranked
system if you guys are into car
games I think you should really try this
game it seems more polished and balanced
than other card games I've played I find
myself having the best games I've had of
any card game it's really fun that's
always been playing by the way last week
either wants to hang out I'm like listen
listen baby
here's your quip I'm playing wedges guys
here's another amazing thing
I think else girls legends is the first
game of effort to this if you connect
your Bethesda account to twitch and you
watch somebody on twitch playing legends
then you get random free drops that's
really cool I don't think any company's
ever done I think the first one do that
it's a really fun game if you like card
games give it a try go to Bethesda net
and open your free account it's free to
play played for 30 minutes you're gonna
be hooked I guarantee it alright thank
you to our sponsors guys if you're in
the market for a toothbrush razors are
you looking for a fun new video game
consider trying those products out to
help support the show would mean a lot
to us alright thank you guys so what do
we so what do you think do we step back
into the eye of the storm
send the nudes would then send the nudes
are you guys ready for the nudes people
yeah
send the nudes okay maybe I'll yeah
let's take a quick like one-minute break
we regroup oh yeah yeah into deep you
guys alright let's take a quick
one-minute break I'm just gonna going to
discuss with my allies here and don't go
away terrible terrible things are gonna
happen if you leave that's just a proven
fact we've done polls on that 50% of the
people who stopped watching perish
within 30 minutes they just perish
all right so oh yeah and one other thing
everybody who is going on twitch Prime
have to give a big THANK at all you guys
haven't give you a shout out in a minute
mm-hmm if you don't want to buy any of
those products but you want to support
the show if you have Amazon Prime you
can attach it connect it to your twitch
account and subscribe for free every
month using Amazon Prime y'all are the
heroes and the salt of this very earth
thank you so much to all you guys
means a lot thank you thank you thank
you appreciate you helps to show it a
lot all right I'm gonna take I'm
seriously just gonna be one minute I
just want to regroup so we'll be back
after a quick quick break thank you guys
thank you for joining us today we have
so you brought the cameraman and we're
gonna get we're snapping a photo here
okay so doing so there we go okay all
right oh go we're doing ham OSHA's I
thought they were stuff and anything
let's do the big no no don't don't leave
if you don't move until Jimmy gives you
the green light yeah then what do we
call this well shine why is it called a
WoW shot it's like the size of his dick
right Wow right
got him right Wow awesome alright wait
hold on can you move it's okay sorry
about that I'm sorry dude
I'm really sorry man well thanks for
joining us today I was a it was a
pleasure I hope you don't get stabbed or
shot I wish you health and happiness and
all the attention what is your what is
your advice for me to get famous you're
smarter than me with the entertainment
okay if you okay if you want to get
famous without this is no body no this
is a good advice oh you know what I
don't know
got no advice for you mine was an
accident Jimmy but I don't know that the
mean I think you're too mean I think you
have to tone it down a little bit like
you can't like there's this one here
like hello I want to point out this one
go a little easier yeah because you can
be funny without being like vicious
yeah vicious and I know you don't mean
to be vicious cuz you're but it comes
off users you have a sweetheart you have
a golden heart you're a golden man I'm a
good guy but I people don't see it well
I get like uh where's the sound death
there's this one where you walk into a
candy store and you says you're a big
girl you're a big girl South Beach one
yeah and so you can and so hurt to her
it's like oh [ __ ] man yeah I mean sure
I'm insecure about being fat and I made
it worse yeah yeah I get it yeah but on
the other hand there's probably a market
for people who just like that you're
mean so I would say either tone it down
or kick it up yeah so either go back to
the hood I'm not going to do two pranks
you know what I don't want to get killed
I just like the insult comment on the
street maybe you're right maybe go down
a notch so I have a more percentage of
people that accept it I like that idea
better oh are you gonna phrase it as
insult comedy let them know maybe yeah I
don't know like hey I do insult comedy
just let you know I'm you know I'm a
little outrageous and are you okay with
that if you're not we won't fix actly
that's that so if so the real they'll
know ahead of time I do you be my agent
I'll be your manager I'll go even
further I'll be your maid of your agent
your manager and your lawyer that's 25%
let's make it 40% Colonel Parker got
away with it why can't you what what's
40% of zero that's 40 wait can we get
40% of the dentistry is the big number
you watch Derek think so they're always
like listen if I'm going to invest in
you I need all the businesses not just
one yeah so I need 40 percent of the
dentistry that won't happen my wife who
is that Kevin that was Mark yeah that
was more I'm obsessed with Shark Tank
do you like the Prophet you should watch
the Prophet oh that's another
we show where the guy goes in and he
looks at businesses it's people process
product and he looks at business how to
help them and get the revenues better
cut their overhead and most of the
businesses aren't doing well so I watch
a lot of shows to hell so forth do I get
40% or know you get whatever value I
want 40% of the dentistry take take 50
why are we stopping okay all right so
I'll put your cable on touches my ass
okay Jimmy yes is there any more
interviews or we oh my and we finished
your being you know and am I being a
Jackie you know it's the night video
babe you know no old cartoons gags
they'd have like a long cane and is that
where we're going yeah cheese and bring
out the giant cane okay well thanks for
having me they love you come out for us
Thanks I love ya I have an open
invitation uh if you're if you're bored
Tamura have nothing to do and you want
to get around with the Jewish kid for a
couple hours they dress it's the you
know where you can email me if you want
to come and we'll be will be there
tomorrow after lunch from about 1:00 to
5:00 I have a Cabana okay and you're
more than welcome to be my guest Thank
You Jimmy I love you as much as we kid
around and have fun
one last thing Ethan your pants today
are about a half inch high up in a
crotch that's why your eyes are batting
and blinking a little bit you got to
loosen up the pants a little bit
or get another tailor okay anything
about the camera guy camera guys it's
his first job and last job I mean the
lens caps still want Sarkis you got to
do a little something this mean for
Christ's sake well let's count you work
with Jimmy again
I pay that's all that matters cash cash
on the Barrelhead well you've got
dentist money
what are dentists there's too much money
well here's my deal with you could you
help me you just need to come to New
Jersey you don't pay when you come to me
could you help me a lot really nice yeah
that's what I do for people that are
good to me Oh would you say all you need
to do we show up anyway I told you that
when you lived in New York word
general dentistry model and we do pretty
much a lot of specialty procedures with
the exception of worth though we don't
do and surgical impactions we don't do
but almost everything else we do in
their locations would you sit in this
dentist's chair but I'm different I'm
different when I'm when I'm when I'm
what I'm working do you put people on
during them work on them well if they
ask me for gears you know what I do I
give them electric you know cuz I always
turn me on especially the middle-aged
ladies oh oh oh oh he wears that yeah
here he goes
uh-oh what's this oh it's a vibrating
toothbrush guys I have to give that to
my middle-aged ladies that are lonely
it's actually really good it's a great
toothbrush you know what I told one
dental patient the other day I didn't
bring out the cane den no I said when
we're done get dressed and use the
mouthwash she did okay good so I do wear
the sunglasses when you're at work rocks
guys welcome back to the HTTP podcast
live unfortunately alright how was that
that was a ride that was a ride it was
um it was some pretty uh pretty powerful
stuff out there I think we made we get
we think we broke some new ground though
yeah I mean you got him to get real for
a couple like two seconds yeah yeah I
mean there was there was a little [ __ ]
in the armor right the end there too it
seemed like that guard came down right
there was a some realness theories and
you know tone it down a little bit all
right whatever of that was a interesting
experience for you that's let's do
another starts and just do it from the
news okay just go straight news let's
just restart and go to the news and cut
it from there yep Jake I wouldn't do
that
I just wouldn't do that and crawl up
there alright back here
alright so in the news this week August
11th 2017 first up this one's this one's
exciting actually we've got uh we got a
little h3 send news update for you
remember a couple weeks ago we talked
about how in Baltimore we were going to
give a no murder weekend a tribe wasn't
it an honor of some holiday sex it
wasn't you know it was it was it's kind
of a tragic thing it was like a mother
who had a kid
ohad or something and was just like you
know let's let's do this let's do this
Baltimore we can we can go one weekend
without killing anybody right right
wrong not just one two murders over the
no murder weekend it was almost like an
invitation for them yeah I feel like you
know it's a really pretty serious troll
I really thought it would work well it's
like you know even like the most
hardened criminals should be like
somebody's children died yeah that's all
put down our GATS as they call them they
do call them that and have a peaceful
weekend Baltimore is a rough place man
yeah yeah no I mean it has that
reputation and and it is on pace to
actually set the record for its highest
annual homicide tool this year someone's
breaking records oh there you go
there you go you know and they were they
were trying to you know pump the brakes
on that a little bit and yeah
unfortunately 40 hours into the
grassroots suit ceasefire a 24 year old
man was fatally shot and then within a
few hours of that a 37 year old was also
it's I mean it's terrible I feel bad
laughing but I mean when we talked about
this last time we all kind of knew that
like whedon well we took bets I think I
think yeah
come on they can not kill each other for
one page yeah
one day maybe but this was three days
this is a 72 hours 72 what was like from
what I overeat I know he's a god if you
base your start small starts you know
come on Frank envision no clothes family
they yeah no more shooting other people
day was there any quick answer for quick
kisses reported on the ground that was
actually yeah that 37 year old we got a
same person all right what's next all
right so next up so you know hold on let
me go and get this up there we go so you
know there's been a lot of talk about
dabbing on the havoc on haters lately
and and you know I guess it's just we
need to take stock of the fact that we
live in a country where it is in fact
okay to dab on haters yeah oh yeah cuz
in Saudi Arabia this famous singer was
arrested for tabbing during a concert so
Jack films been asking the question what
what happened this is what happens and
here he is [ __ ] rationale for for
banning dabbing there it is that was a
that was like a [ __ ] jihad dad that
was like [ __ ] straight up Akbar dad
here we go we're going in slow-mo no
good look at that wind up damn dog
that's when the bombs go off the trigger
yo why was he arrested
so justified yeah so apparently you know
this wasn't this is a law on the books
this wasn't arbitrary it is actually
illegal in Saudi Arabia to dad why
because it is a part of the country's
far-reaching anti-drug like you know
they're they're very serious about that
over inside of you baby I know
substances at all and I think you can
even drink there right like literally
nothing
having into the equation somehow it is
it's associated with drugs I guess is
how they view it well I don't know about
Western culture they don't want
penetrating their society or something
but it somehow somehow it was decided
yeah yeah it was officially prohibited
by the country's anti-drug Authority as
many considered a reference to weed and
other narcotic what well I don't know
about you guys but when I dab it's just
an elaborate injection oh I see okay I'm
trying out here listen I can't outlet
Jimmy came in how am I gonna compete
with the other why don't you you know
what you are you really diving at me
whoa I love that someone went to prison
for dabbling though I would cherish that
yeah I'll never go out for a long time
yeah me neither son never go - sorry
bruh I'll never go to the Emirates those
guys actually own slaves
actually I can I I hold those countries
in in the highest contempt honestly yeah
it's kind of coming there theocracy I
mean of course it's insane I mean yeah
but but it's even beyond like the
theocracy like they they bring in like
Asian immigrants to do like hard labor
and then they confiscate their passports
so they can't leave effectively holding
them slaves yeah don't go there don't
[ __ ] lock you up for looking for
dabbing right like you're hanging out
with your friends you're throwing up
dabs next thing you know you're one of
the alright so next in China a granny
gang that was all recruited from some
ballroom dancing classes was busted and
harassed it for terrorizing their
victims into paying their debts
basically this guy got these grand
Thurs to be his like little army of
enforcers Hornet right but it's more
like a repo Nance right right so like
you know normally this would be like a
guy like Jimmy Lee come and break your
thumbs or whatever mm-hm
over here we have a whole slew how many
did they say hold on I took note of this
or any gang a bunch of women aged up to
70 were enforcers I was enlisted by this
act or outdoor ballroom dancing class
they would intimidate people with
megaphones before confronting them
directly so can you imagine this like
just on the street you're walking down
the street and you have like a dozen or
so elderly women with megaphones that is
what was his thought process in
recruiting you know elderly women well
so it goes a little bit further they
would tear the tear the clothes off
their female victims and slow off their
own clothes but we're confronting men
apparently to suggest that they had been
sexually assaulted fine okay so how they
found it Beijing News reported that one
gang member said and I quote I had
nothing to do so I thought it would be
fun to try I mean what are you doing
you're living in some small town and I
mean I'll tip the beneath it's creative
creative solutions in like they strip
their clothing off I forgot to a key
point is that they were also given free
meals and you know how old people are
that other page yeah they were they were
paid in meals
China's weird dude yeah it's a little
odd I mean I'm sure there's this weird
of [ __ ] that happens here too though to
be honest but this time it was China so
there you go I do recall a couple weeks
ago there was yeah that one story sticks
out about the the vegans who rescued or
was in Canada no that was
all the meerkats or whatever of the year
yeah that was uh oh god shut up Walmart
yeah next story Walmart you guys see
this this actually made some pretty
major news so you may have already seen
this for sign marketing gun oh I saw
that was that real I thought that was
photos I thought it was photoshopped ooh
this is completely real oh this wait
what you're looking at is a gun rack of
rifles and above it it says own the
squirrel year like a hero
it's a Walmart and I'm so [ __ ] wrong
so Walmart immediately came out and said
you know this is not officially
sanctioned and like they wanted to know
like what store did this and it cracked
I saw that and I was like this is a
photo shop it's funny but there's no way
it's gotta be a disgruntled employee
right that that was where my mind went
I mean I get but it had to be somebody
who had access to their marketing
material you know what I mean like they
got shipped those placards wait where
the [ __ ] does walmart so rightful yeah
that most of the country actually I've
never seen no no I don't like in
California but in most of the mics not
you can Walmart right now that's kind of
terrifying yeah I'm on the school year
like a hero every day low prices on
their rifles
yeah Walmart responded to some of the
comments by calling the display truly
awful and horrible - thank you thank you
clarifying that it is truly awful and
horrible but the prices are next level
and I'm just saying you know if you have
some beef we have the best prices right
oh my and just to be clear I guess this
isn't the first time that Walmart has
been busted for this kind of thing uh
last September 11th they came under a
lot of fire
wait now this is unrelated I have seen
this
well I've seen this one too like it now
people want it alright let's see what
this one always long said that the best
way to commemorate any national you know
tragedy or holiday is to sell mattresses
of course but I love you have always
said that and ever since I've met you
yeah it's annoying how often you say
that is what am I saying people you know
like Ethan the mattress guy it is kind
of a funny bit but it's so brutally
tasteless the context of it just showing
up on the television right it's pretty
shocking yeah this is the one that I was
looking for originally so this is what I
got in trouble for will never forget and
in power of Cola yeah in honor of the
three thousand fallen we shall build
this monument to consumerism and sugary
drinks
I guess you said three thousand fallen
well luckily the price is three thirty
three in honor of all the tears I never
thought I saw myself talking about
Walmart this much grab yourself a coke
and a shotgun and be the year of this
year it's below zero your school needs
oh yeah so so yeah Walmart doing their
best to uh so if you have any
information never guess who put up that
sign on the right this national tragedy
of 9/11 went like from the worst thing
that's ever happened on American soil to
a commercial holiday in like a short
like how long has it been I mean a
little over ten years right I mean
because it's I was 40 years no like so
15 this will be 16 that's a quick
turnaround we're getting better at this
right but this but that commercial was
from like a year or two ago so even more
credit even more I
back traditionally it takes like 30 to
50 years to turn a tragedy to long was
it until they I mean I know it's not a
commercial but there was those movies
about 9/11 oh that was like two years
later yeah that was like the next month
yeah Affleck was on a [ __ ] write was
on the 67th floor calling his wife it's
so gross [ __ ] their songs about never
forget well I'm gonna pick myself up a
Pepsi for sure or that's a Coke sorry
come on be brand family I think that's
actually it it was a light light slow
news week yeah at least as far as I mean
you know oh yes send the nudes we have
to change the interest so it's dancing
yes funnier all right well ela yep how
you feeling you got anything you want to
talk about well this was a this was a
wild ride how do we do this this episode
was pretty unusual yeah I think you know
you'll have to watch it back you you
guys did better and I'll say the
comments are the the twitch chat it was
pretty critical of old Jimmy there but
well I thought I didn't want to be too
rude that was what you had the perfect
tone really meeting and Mimi's always a
risk right you don't know what you're
getting into I don't think I'm gonna do
it anymore honestly because it seems
great on paper but it's like when you're
sitting in in a room with somebody on a
podcast setting you need you need
editing mm-hmm or it needs to be like
really short like I can't sit in a room
with Jimmy for like two hours well and
he in particular is just somebody that
he is almost I'd almost because he did a
little bit at the end there but almost
incapable of letting his guard down all
right just he has he feels like if he's
in front of camera he has to be on right
and you know it that's not interesting
you can go watch his videos and see all
of his cringe s yeah
well I hope this episode was uh alas I
was a riot it was interesting we're
trying new stuff here guys thanks for
sticking around and hanging out with us
during these these you know we're we're
still exploring what number episode is
this like 19 18 or 19 yeah I mean it's
crazy we've even done that
yeah but like Joe Rogan just hit a
thousand find out so you know all right
my dream for the shows I want to be
bigger and better we're always trying to
figure out new formats and stuff so
thank you guys for coming along for the
ride and exploring these new territories
with us I think this show has a lot of
potential I think we're already we're
already one of the most viewed podcasts
in the whole world really isn't saying I
mean when you actually think about it's
incredible we're getting like between
streaming and on YouTube at least 1.2
million views per episode so I thank you
guys for joining us on the show and I
and we're working hard every week to
make it a better more fun experience to
watch so thank y'all did our best this
week the viewership was consistent I'll
say that - I didn't notice there's a lot
of people saying like oh my god oh my
god please make it stop but they you
don't want to look away yeah it hurts
cringe videos have the most views yes
that's the beautiful second cartridge
mistake was not bringing any cringe we
shoulda gear all right well I'm gonna
end the show we'll stick around on
Twitch to say what up to the pimps and n
pimps out there the super troopers
giving at home thank you so much for
watching thank you to our sponsors thank
you to everyone who hooked it up on
Twitch prime god bless you papa bless
you next Friday
holy foot holy
come on Ida holy guacamole my dogs I
don't want to say what it is because
there's a chance at me there's always a
chance these things don't work yeah
but if this works out it's gonna be our
biggest episode ever problem bringing
the cranes clear
don't come with that oh my god I hope it
Oh God Ike I'm on the fence with Jimmy
I'm like I hope it works out and then
half of me is like oh it doesn't work
out so I don't have to so make sure to
tune in next Friday
[Applause]
[Music]